welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness could include
dozens of insane marvel cameos and since
so much of this film's imagery seems
connected to the animated what if what
if the star of that series captain
carter shows up in this film the
prospect of hayley atwell going full
hemsworth for a multiverse of madness
cameo just got an uatu wink when marvel
recently placed all the marvel one-shot
short films on the primary mcu page on
disney plus including the one starring
agent carter agent carter i broke down
the agent coulson short films of this
series but now we've gotta revisit this
agent carter short because however
connected it is to the main mcu timeline
and the two season agent carter series
on abc this all gives us some new
insight into how a live-action captain
carter could be launched into the mcu so
let's break it down okay this agent
carter one shot was released as a bonus
feature on the iron man 3 blu-ray in
2013 and at the time was seen as a sort
of proof of concept to give agent carter
her own series season one dropping in
2015 followed by season two in 2016. but
this short opens by revisiting peggy's
final moments with steve rogers in 1945
during the events of captain america the
first avenger give me your coordinates
i'll find you a safe landing site
there's not gonna be a safe landing but
i can try and force it down
i'll get howard on the line he'll know
what to do
peggy
this is my choice but this sequence has
actually been re-edited now we hear
steve's line over the radio from peggy's
perspective whereas before the camera
cut to him to say the line they also
changed all the music and removed a lot
of line you're gonna need a rain check
on that dance
a week next saturday at the stalk club
you got it eight o'clock on the dock
don't you dare be late
you know i still don't know how to dance
i'll show you how
just be there
we'll have the band play something slow
steve
instead his final words are really just
her name before he cuts to radio silence
peggy
steve
[Music]
steve
so before all these moments are really
playing out from steve's perspective now
as this read plays in peggy's memory
it's less about the whole dance
conversation and more about how her time
with steve was cut short now i know we
are in one galaxy right now but i gotta
ask if you want to go to another one do
you yearn to boldly go where no one has
gone before from your phone well star
trek fleet command is a free-to-play
mobile open world strategic mmo
available on ios and android customize
your fleet and crew to dominate the
galaxy in this award-winning star trek
game experience the entire star trek
universe with all your favorite
franchises recruit iconic characters
from the next generation the original
series the jj abrams films discovery and
more including kirk picard and dana
build powerful ships like the uss
enterprise and klingon bird of prey
there's a lot to do in the game forge
alliances conquer territories and
explore new worlds on intergalactic
missions i'm currently working to defeat
the borg and keep us from getting
dissimilated you're welcome i really
like that you can unlock and play with
some of the all-time great star trek
characters like scotty and spock if you
think i'm not gunning to get worf you
must not have any klingon blood in you
if you reach level 5 today you can
unlock origins burnham reach level 10 by
february 10th and you can get the shards
to tear up your origins burnham to rank
2. so download and play star trek fleet
command today from the link in this
video's description live long and
prosper so we jump ahead one year later
to 1946 when agent carter works for the
ssr strategic scientific reserve the
agency that they all worked for in the
first cap film before shield she works
under agent flynn bradley whitford who
actually came back to voice colonel
flynn in the first episode of what if
every last drop of that dr erskine serum
went into you and if we get lucky
someday your blood might tell us how to
make a real super soldier and you'll
notice in animation the character was
given grayer hair presumably to match
whitford's current look compared to his
hair color in the one shot why would
they change it for a scene that
technically takes place years before
this live action one shot unless marvel
has plans to introduce whitford's
character in live action along with a
live-action version of peggy from this
era that what if scene showed flynn
taking her blood samples and in the
final shot of the season peggy found who
we think is steve in the modern era in
the hydra stomper armor so there may be
some dark live-action plot in the works
in another universe in which flynn plays
a thaddeus ross type role in corrupting
steve into a brainwashed super soldier
and i bring this up because the what if
producers even said they planned a
subplot where steve rogers became
captain hydra anyway here flynn gets
this intel call zodiac is on the move
crossing the white stone bridge in a
green sedan this enemy is considered
armed and extremely dangerous ah that's
actually the voice of iron man 3
director shane black there and yes it's
a two agent mission but flynn sends
three guys all of them fail compare that
to the three to five man mission that
peggy receives later that she completes
alone in her drawer peggy keeps a photo
of skinny steve steve later finds this
same photo framed on peggy's desk in
camp lehigh in endgame and yes peggy
takes the mission call we have a locked
position on zodiac
40.6518 degrees north 73.9
degrees west actually when you plug in
these coordinates it takes you to an
address in brooklyn on rogers avenue as
peggy beats up the thugs music plays
inside
this song is actually called deep in the
night by singer songwriter lori linner
composed as a mr sandman type jingle
leonard's songs are actually featured in
the agent carter series peggy restrains
the guy i need you to scream for help
yeah i love how this is essentially
peggy's version of get help the trick
thor and loki use in ragnarok please my
brother is dying get help help him
party thor being a guardian of the
multiverse captain carter later teams up
with in what if and then after she takes
down the thugs she finds the mysterious
zodiac serum its blue color suggests it
could have maybe been a super soldier
serum offshoot but this serum actually
does come back in a captain america the
winter soldier prelude comic stolen by a
terrorist named baker who wanted to
unleash it in chicago's willis tower
before cap natasha and rumlow's strike
team stop him so presumably it was a
kind of chemical weapon that's why the
thugs outside tell peggy that there was
a kind of gas leak then peggy gets a
dressing down from flynn there are
protocols in place no one is above
protocols not even captain america's old
flame how dare you you were grieving
so they kept you on so that you would
feel useful
i call it pity but then flynn gets a
call from howard stark the younger
version played by dominic cooper i'd say
that last night was more a notch in her
belt than a feather in her cap
yes sir what are your orders phillips
and i wanted to come to washington
second
tell her she'll be running shield with
me and yes howard is wearing the same
bathrobe that tony stark shows up
wearing in iron man 2. a postcard scene
actually shows howard sitting alongside
dum-dum dugen from the first cap film a
member of the howling commandos both of
them ugly and women wearing this new
french fashion item called a bikini so i
guess whether they're flynn or the good
guys boys will be boys
so when the agent carter series was
first developed its producers which
actually included in-game writers marcus
and mcfeely intended it to take place
before the one shot peggy's ssr days
leading up to her time with shield but
episode 1 of agent carter flashes back
to that window kick in the one shot and
as the series progresses the timeline
really just gets muddy like season 2
takes place in 1947 which is after when
the one shot takes place but now that
what if brought back both hayley
atwell's voice and bradley whitford's
voice in their roles i don't think it's
a stretch to say that just like the
alternate universe where peggy carter
becomes captain carter this one shot
could be yet another alternate universe
in the overall origin story of captain
carter future head of the captain
britain core of the multiverse james
darcy as edwin jarvis remains the one
character who originated in either
agency shield or agent carter in this
case agent carter to appear in the mcu
films he showed up in endgame really
when it comes to what makes something
canon whatever past reference is made or
the intent of past creators is not as
important as how excited the creative
heads currently in control the universe
feel about a character and peggy carter
is definitely a character marvel studios
has a soft spot for not only did captain
carter lead off what if show producers
have confirmed she will return as a
vocal character in future seasons brian
andrews and ac bradley pushed for atwell
to return as a live action captain
carter in the suit marvel exec brad
winterbomb even said referring to
captain carter's future quote i think
you can tell that in this next saga the
multiverse is gonna be crucial so again
if the matching visuals between
multiverse of madness and the what if
animation are intentional and if that
dark strange variant in the multiverse
madness trailer is actually a live
action strange supreme from those
episodes i highly suspect we are also
going to see a live action captain
carter in this multiverse crisis because
she is a cat from another universe with
experience fighting on multiversal
fronts whether it's squid monsters look
out gargantos or even bigger bads look
out galactus you can check out all of
our great merch options at
noraexmurch.com and if you live in the
chicago area you have got to come see
new rockstars live on february 11th 8pm
talia hall ticket link in the
description you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
me rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching watcher
[Music]
you